und an dieser stelle vielleicht mal ein
gepflegtes ski heil freunde ich wette
viele von ihnen liebe zuschauer haben
sich in diesem ausnahmewinter wieder
begeistert das eine oder andere
kreuzband gerissen
also ja jetzt nichts gegen skiurlaub
generell aber viele leute verhalten nur
noch zum feiern und saufen hin
das gehört auch zur wahrheit und man
kann sich ja wenigstens mal bewusst
machen das ist alles was ich sage man
kann sich bewusst machen was der
massentourismus da oben in den bergen so
anrichtet denn egal ob schnee fällt wie
dieses jahr oder nicht die alpen werden
in jedem fall auf links gezogen
im skigebiet pitztaler gletscher wird
ein berg weggesprengt um einen zeh weg
zu verbreitern
ja was steht auch im weg ja da läuft ein
regelrechter krieg skifahrer gegen natur
quasi ein ski hat möchte und und sogar
in schneereichen wintern arbeiten die
schneekanonen wie blöde einfach mal
schön als für die konsistenz auf der
piste in einer normalen saison werden in
den alpen 70.000 hektar beschneit das
verbraucht dreimal so viel wasser wie
die stadt münchen pro jahr für die
ureinwohner da oben ist es teilweise
hart bei heidi zum beispiel vor der
hütte da sieht es auch nicht mehr aus
wie früher alles zugebaut und dann
kommen die schneekanonen
naja
und der geist peter arbeitet als
stricher in kitzbühel das ist der gang
der dinge die frage ist wie lange der
ganze aufwand überhaupt noch lohnt jetzt
wo die schneegrenze schon seit jahren
immer weiter nach oben wandert sich
verschiebt und die gletscher schmelzen
klar könnte man auch urlaub in kleinen
ruhigen skigebieten machen aber geiler
ist halt schon wenn dich der heli auf
die letzten unberührten gipfel fliegt
damit auch die murmeltiere den spaß am
leben verlieren oder ja natürlich aber
winterschlaf in ihr überschätzt mit dem
hubschrauber zum skifahren da stellen
sich schon fragen muss es das geben ja
das ist möglich weil unsere welt ist ja
unsere welt braucht es gut dass wir das
gern kommt meine damen und herren ja
manche pessimistisch der experten
behaupten in 20 bis 30 jahren gibt es in
den alpen gar keine skigebiete mehr
umgekehrt könnte man natürlich
argumentieren lasst es uns verdammt noch
mal genießen so lange es dauert ein
langweiler rumsitzen und nichts kaputt
machen klickt euch nicht mehr
dann macht mit bei der großen alten
après ski party skifahrer snowboarder
nicht rumjammern zerstören
für ein perfektes schneevergnügen
verpulvern die den inhalt von 420
speicher sehen die wir in die hässliche
landschaft geballert haben und dann
sprechen wir eine eigene route in den
berg und benennen sie nach deiner moda
bei uns gibt es nachhaltigen urlaub denn
hier machst du die umwelt nachhaltig
kaputt und keine sorge
du wirst dich niemals rechtfertigen
müssen denn nach zwei liter jagatee
kannst du dich sowieso an nichts
erinnern
skiurlaub zeigt der natur wer den
längsten hat
[Applaus]
so und es ist tatsächlich so vor allem
in den österreichischen alpen findet
gerade ein regelrechtes wettrüsten stadt
das ist nicht übertrieben welcher skiort
hat mehr pistenkilometer wer bietet mehr
entertainment mehr geile events damit
skifahren allein ist es da längst nicht
mehr getan
das weiß auch der kollege ulrich von
heesen der heute in tirol sein eigenes
skigebiet eröffnet
ja ja ja mein skigebiet das klingt jetzt
so nach personenkult jedoch gar nicht um
mich welche auch wenn der ort sagt
ulrich heißt und da hinten jetzt mein
gesicht mit fackeln in den berg gebrannt
wird nun morgen auf 2800 metern diese
riesigen akte reiterstatue aus eis von
mir enthüllt wird für die fans aber
letztlich geht es doch um unseren
wunderbaren sport
china macht mal die musik lauter man
hört die schneekanonen
es ist so schön hier saugeil hinter
massen von schnee erinnert mich an
stalingrad nur dass hier mehr russen
sehen
aber
ja
das hat doch mit wintersport überhaupt
nichts mehr zu tun ist alles not wir
welche haben sie mein gesehen was sie
anderen spinner machen hier in sölden
haben die chance mit pistenraupen
ballett hubschraubern feuerwerk
menschenopfern oder ja mein erzfeind
günther aloys aus ischgl der plant
ernsthaft einem snowboard park in form
von pamela anderson und eine kirche auf
der piste wurde mit ski an rhein und
direkt wieder raus fragt habt ist eine
blöde an gema sei aber da mach ich
fertig ich baue jetzt einen zwei
quadratkilometer großen weihwasser see
auf dem der papst dir persönlich die
beichte abnimmt auf schlittschuhe
ich dachte der trend geht wieder zum
kleinen nachhaltigen skiurlaub ja klar
sicher ist auch wichtig
es gibt jetzt sogar ein eigenes
gütesiegel für nachhaltige chemie
skigebiete hier morgen da können von mir
aus dem ganzen unrasiert neben urlaub
machen hier ist party zone
das signal oben auf dem berg schmeißen
sie meine untertanen laden
[Musik]
ulrich und hilfen
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße